(engaging music)
- The first Scorsese film I
watched was "Taxi Driver".
I watched it with my dad
and I think I was about 15.
And we watched a couple of
films over that weekend,
and I said, "Dad, I think I really wanna
"have a go at this acting."
And he was, "Do you?"
I went, "Yeah I really do, I'm honest."
And he went, "Okay."
And we went to the video
shop, and we got three films
and one of which was "Taxi Driver".
The others, one was "The Godfather"
and one was "Deer Hunter".
So straight away I was kind of immersed
in classic filmmaking,
do you know what I mean?
Beautiful storytelling, strong characters.
And stories which meant
something, which had a voice
and which was talking
about the human condition.
(slow jazz music)
For me, "Taxi Driver" just
literally blew my mind.
I'd never seen that world,
I hadn't seen New York in that way before,
but to see that richness of that world
and the darkness and the depth
of what he captured just
absolutely blew my mind
and a performance which
it's completely outstanding.
And to watch Travis Bickle go through
that massive journey he goes
on, do you know what I mean?
His hatred for the world
and then his feeling a part
of the outside of society
and, that beautiful opening,
and that music at the beginning,
do you know what I mean?
The orchestral music would begin
and the lights of the city.
I was mesmerized.
You know where Harvey
Keitel stood on a stoop
and he comes in, and De Niro comes in
and they have little chat.
- Is your name Matthew?
Need some action?
- Officer, I swear I'm clean,
I'm just waiting here for a friend.
- And just to see him in
that hat and that vest
and the imagery of the
characters and stuff,
it really was amazing.
(upbeat jazz music)
The next film I watched straight away
which was literally a week
later, I watched "Mean Streets"
and that was...
(blows burst of air)
It was a world I knew nothing about,
but was obsessed with then,
do you know what I mean?
And obsessed with that whole era
and that culture in America at that time.
Yeah, a lot of British
actors were kinda brought up
on that stuff as well,
do you know what I mean?
And it really resonated.
But the character study was amazing.
I'd never seen character studies like that
do you know what I mean?
And then I started watching
a lot of films after that.
But to see the way these people
were portrayed was breathtaking.
(traditional Italian music)
"Goodfellas" is still I mean
it's in my top five films
of all time, do you know what I mean?
And again, that, all the
different characters,
all the colors of the
tapestry that he puts together
of all these different people.
And the thing is,
the thing about Marty's
films in particular,
is they're never one dimensional
these characters at all,
do you know what I mean?
Been lucky enough to work with him,
that's kind of that's
the process what he does.
He always tries to help you find a way
of making your characters
humane, do you know what I mean?
Even if they're psychotic killers
or whatever in any respect.
He always tries to find
this other element,
to show that the humanity
within that character
at some point or at some
level do you know what I mean?
And these are people that are...
Look, these are people
that are shooting people.
Do you know what I mean?
They're killing people,
they're robbing things,
they're stealing this,
they're killing people.
(gun shots)
But yet we go on
that journey with them,
do you know what I mean?
They become likable,
(car explodes)
although we shouldn't like them.
As a fact, we shouldn't
like these kind of people
but we do, we get immersed in that story,
do you know what I mean?
And that's what he does,
he makes the characters gregarious,
you're really drawn to them characters,
and you end up rooting
especially, in "Goodfellas"
you end up rooting for them,
do you know what I mean?
'cause he's a good man,
but it's the world he gets caught up in.
(traditional Italian music)
Obviously, there was
the scene with Joe Pesci
"Clown, do I amuse you?"
That I mean that, when I first
saw it, I was blown away.
- I'm funny how, I mean
funny like I'm a clown,
I amuse you.
I make you laugh, I'm
here to fucking amuse you.
What do you mean funny?
Funny how, how am I funny?
- I'm not, just you know
how you tell the story what?
- I watched it, and I think I watched it
in the cinema first,
and then when I got it on video,
I just remember rewinding
that a good few times I did
watch that scene, and just
how he (clicks fingers) flips.
- You're a funny guy.
(laughs)
- What do you mean?
You mean do I talk, what?
- Just, you know, you're just funny.
It's you're funny yeah,
the way you tell the
story, and everything.
- Funny how?
(traditional Italian music)
- He just goes.
But then again, you feel uncomfortable
for the other characters as well.
But you're kind of excited
about what he's gonna do,
do you know what I mean?
So that was one particular
scene I do watch it
over and over again.
- Get the fuck out of here, Tommy.
- You motherfucker!
I almost had 'em, I almost had 'em.
(funky music)
- It's his storytelling both visually
and with the characters that
he tells his stories with,
do you know what I mean?
You just become immersed in it.
He is a master at telling stories,
do you know what I mean?
Like I said about characters
with faults, with defects,
do you know what I mean?
He portrays the human
condition beautifully I think.
There's very few for me.
For me, he's the best director there is.
To be able to work with him a few times
has been absolutely unbelievable.
And when I work with him
on "Gangs of New York"
on my last day he said to me,
"We'll do this again sometime."
And I was, "You can't say
that to me and not do it."
He was, "No, I promise you,
we'll do this again sometime."
Yeah, and he stuck to his word.
And I'm extremely humbled and very honored
to be able to work with
such a wonderful man.
- [Interviewer] Did he
say that to you at the end
of "The Irishman" as well?
- I can't say.
No, yeah, yeah, oh, yeah.
No, no.
Hmm, hmm, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
(funky music)